when French president Emmanuel macron
arrived in Brussels for the European
leaders Summit last week he warned China
Europe won't be an open market for
Beijing
we have been naive we were an open
Supermarket we need to set new rules in
the game and check our critical
infrastructure for vulnerabilities
but macron was also clearly displeased
with the German Chancellor's plan to
travel to China next month a trip the
French President where we would send the
wrong message at a time when the block
is determined to curb China's growing
economic and political influence
globally
when fears of an impounding recession in
Europe were growing German Chancellor
Olaf Schultz announced in September and
nearly 200 billion dollar relief package
French officials felt betrayed
they were hoping for a coordinated EU 8
scheme to save businesses facing the
tough choice of cutting costs or
shutting down
for France EU countries are in the same
boat decisions have to be made at EU not
National level he wants the E to speak
as a single voice
since Russia invaded Ukraine earlier
this year the EU is having a hard time
acting as a united front
but macron was Furious when baleen
ditched european-made fighter jets and
chose to buy F-35 warplanes Instead
This is an existential crisis it raises
questions about how strong is solidarity
among EU countries despite their
different interests yet their
geopolitical influence as a block should
be maintained but when President macron
and Chancellor Schultz met briefly in
Brussels it was to reassure allies they
are committed to working together
France and Germany were the driving
force behind the idea of a stronger
broader and a United EU but these are
difficult times a war in Europe High
inflation soaring Energy prices have
brought the global economy and deepened
divisions among EU Nations Paris and
Berlin have managed to overcome many
challenges in the past but Europe's two
major industrial countries may have no
other option but to choose different
paths as they deal with the Fallout of
the Russian invasion of Ukraine Al
Jazeera Paris